his Excellency the governor of New South
Wales and mrs. Hurley the Honourable
Gladys perchick lien Premier of New
South Wales chairman and council members
of the Australia Council of New South
Wales distinguished guests ladies and
gentlemen it's a great joy and a
privilege to stand here on the land
cared for by the gadigal people of the
eora nation I want to recognize and
honor the elders past and present of
this beautiful country that we call home
and celebrate today thank you for stood
in this wonderful place and making it an
environment that we can all enjoy and
cherish together both in our everyday
lives and in special times like this the
theme of Australia Day this year is
everyone every story - strange honor to
have been invited to give this address
and share my story with you it's
obviously an honor to stand in this
amazing tradition following so many
incredible individuals and to be tasked
with giving you a spoken celebration of
what it means to be Australian is a
unique and special gift being a teacher
gives me the opportunity to see and
savor the very best of what Australia is
I get to see students dream of what they
might one day become and achieve I see
them aspire to cure disease to tackle
climate change and fight for the rights
of the disenfranchised I get to watch
them grow into pastry chefs engineers
nurses and even fellow educators
citizens who make a positive difference
in Australian society what makes it all
the more meaningful is that I get to see
students make and achieve these goals in
the nitty gritty mess of everyday life I
get to see students face and overcome
enormous challenges from civilian needs
to socio-economic disadvantage from
broken families and domestic violence to
substance addiction I have the weighty
privilege of seeing not just my students
but entire school communities respond
with care integrity and kindness in some
of the most harrowing circumstances I
think back to the terrible tragedy at
Banksy road public school in November
last year when two boys died in a car
crash accident those two boys were in
year three the same year is my daughter
and I know I'm not the only one for whom
that awful incident struck so very close
to home as time wore on though what
became increasingly clear amid all that
unimaginable grief was the profound
outpouring of love sympathy and service
that centered on that school I remember
my feeling of surprise when I heard that
the school was going to reopen the very
next day and then I read what was said
by our secretary in the department Mark
Scott mark you said the strong view of
the principal and the school community
was the school is so vital as part of
the healing process it's where students
are going to want to come
it's where community members are going
to want to come as a teacher I get to
see those great Australian qualities of
courage compassion and mate ship in
action every day so it's wonderful to
have the honor of celebrating that but
it's also strange for me to be the one
standing here today being a person who
was harassed and isolated for not being
Australian when I was a kid it didn't
seem to matter that I was born in
Cameroon or that I spent my entire
childhood in north rocks supporting the
Parramatta Eels it didn't seem to matter
that I grew up listening to crowded
house and that my favorite food was the
potato scallop that i religiously
purchased for 20 cents at the tuck shop
on my walk home from school each day
know what seemed to matter was that I
didn't look Australian or that at least
I didn't fit what my peers thought mr.
was supposed to look like so I grew up
thinking of Australians as other people
it took me many years to not just
realize that I was genuinely Australian
but to feel that I was and then it took
me several more years after that to see
how being Australian has fundamentally
shaped me as a person and that
conviction is somehow led me here to
stand before you today
I believe one of the defining
characteristics of Australian society is
a we seek to offer a world-class
learning environment to every child in
every school whenever I speak with
teaching colleagues from around the
world it fills me with such pride to
describe the way that our schools labor
to accommodate everyone who walks in the
door and this is actually the reason why
my brother sister and I are Australians
in the first place for the three of us
being Australian wasn't really a
coincidence of birth location it was a
very deliberate choice from our father
who left his birthplace of Malaysia
because its education system didn't
favour someone with his Chinese heritage
he did his matriculation in Melbourne
studied to become a tax accountant at
the Australian National University and
when it came time to raise a family
remaining in Australia seemed the
obvious choice it was so clear in fact
that mum and dad made their commitment
visible in our names Anglo Saxon first
names Anglo Saxon middle names mum and
dad raised us with English as our first
language because they wanted us to grow
up without accents and all the related
challenges that had come with them when
they first moved here they didn't just
want us to live here they wanted us to
belong here this is part of what made
the everyday racism that I grew up with
so frustrating
it wasn't the intimidation or the
mocking or the loneliness that really
bothered me so much as it was my
inability to understand what people
wanted that would satisfy them and make
them stop I'd read it every morning
because I knew I'd have to get ready for
school and I knew what was waiting
for me I became what as a teacher I
would now call a school refuser there
are mornings when I willed myself to
stay in bed and hope that my mom would
give up and trying to get me to school
because it was too late
poor mom was then stuck with me as she
went about her errands sometimes in an
effort to cheer me up and encouraged me
to attend school the next day she'd buy
me a book I'd collect little puzzle
books and choose-your-own-adventure
paperbacks and for a few hours I would
lose myself in another world and become
a hero instead of a loser I loved those
books so much apparently I made that too
obvious because when I returned to
school it didn't take long for my
beliefs to find my treasured belongings
in my bag and steal them I'll always
find them eventually rip to pieces and
scattered it across the playground
another symbol of how holy I fit in in
time I learned that there was nothing I
could do to stop others viewing me as
someone who didn't belong but I think
deep down my parents understood that it
was worth playing the long game on this
one that their sacrifices incoming fear
and our sacrifice isn't staying here
would be worth it that the access to
schools and universities the access to a
better laughing than the one they left
behind would be worth the price we paid
they hoped that we would have
opportunities and freedom to make
choices like they never could but that
was where the next challenge came up my
brother used that freedom to enter the
IT industry right as the dot-com boom
swept the globe my sister became a
dentist the first doctor in the entire
rude dynasty
I gained entry into an academically
competitive selective high school and it
looked like everything was on track for
a perfect three children out of three
who would make it into a lucrative and
socially respectable profession the
migrants dream come true
no one saw what was coming next
I discovered that I wanted to be a
teacher in the 15 years since I made
this discovery many people have
questioned me on this decision
an old friend won't put it to me like
this every year you teach the same
syllabus every day you march to the same
bell times you leave school exhausted
you mark exams and write reports until
you fall asleep then an alarm jolts you
awake and you do it all over again it's
like Groundhog Day with teenagers why
would you do this to yourself I didn't
always want to teach like many young
boys I'd wanted to be a firefighter
sadly I found out that having chronic
asthma didn't exactly place me at the
top of the eligibility list thought I'd
follow my brother into IT but in the
middle of my high school years the
dot-com bubble burst I pictured myself
completing university with a useless
piece of paper in my hands then all at
once through being an army cadet a
prefect a leader in my school's
Christian group and a peer support
mentor to year 7 students as they
entered high school I realized that I
loved helping people learn seeing them
grow in their knowledge and
understanding in their understanding of
the world and in their realization of
what they themselves were capable of
seeing that was an immense source of joy
that's still the reason why I love
teaching today teaching is more than
just a source of joy for me though it's
also a source of moral purpose the last
18 months have been a powerful reminder
of
important education is to our world if
the Trump presidency
Briggs it and our own recent political
conversations have taught us anything
it's that while we live in an age where
we hear more information than ever
we still haven't learned to listen to
those around us and appreciate points of
view other than our own like every year
before at 2017 was littered with
political debates but this year
something was different though each of
the examples I mentioned earlier was
certainly a landmark decision
the most striking thing that this most
recent season wasn't purely the outcomes
that for me
the most striking thing has been our
consistent failure to open dialogue and
form a nuanced understanding of others
across political and ideological lines
in the US the UK and here in Australia
we've shown that while we live in
structurally democratic societies we
struggle to cultivate personally
Democratic relationships instead of
using social media to connect with those
who have different perspectives to us
we've created echo chambers of friends
and followers where we keep precisely
those views that affirm our own beliefs
and denigrate those of others I'll
openly admit that my generation is the
worst at this instead of seeking
multiple independent reports about
current affairs we submit ourselves to
the yoke of informational slavery that
comes from consuming a curated news feed
we scroll and swipe our way through
whatever's received the most likes and
shares with little care for its
journalistic integrity and this
simplistic approach toward understanding
the world has begotten a simplistic
approach toward relating to others while
my generation is the poor for it we're
not the only ones anyone who reads news
from just one paper or his reports from
a single radio station renders
themselves equally
subject to the biases of whoever has
their ear and we all suffer for it we
suffer in the way that it makes us judge
our neighbors who dress differently who
vote differently who speak differently
we suffer in the way that we ourselves
are judged just like I was judged and
bullied as a child but this cycle can be
broken and if it is that education will
be at the heart of how it happens this
is why through a life of fighting
discrimination and government sanctioned
oppression the late Nelson Mandela
declared education is there as powerful
weapon which we can use to change the
world how can this be well my school is
a perfect example almost 2,000 students
more than 60 cultures and languages our
school motto is achieving together our
students form their identities in the
context of grappling with different
accents different values different ways
of thinking our students grow as
citizens while learning everyday to
suspend their instinct to judge by
appearances our students daily
experience is the strength is found in
working hand in hand with those who are
different to us appreciating the things
that unify us without diminishing the
qualities that distinguish us this is
just one aspect of why teaching is so
filled with purpose for me schools are
so much more than just learning facts
it's about fashioning citizens and
giving them a passion to make the world
a better place as the ancient Greek
writer Plutarch put it education is not
the filling of a pail but the lighting
of a fire
that's why I teach but the next question
people usually ask me is why maths the
truth is I never planned to teach this
subject my high school certificate was
stacked towards the humanities I took
drama modern history extension history
and English extension - so when I turned
up at the University of Sydney it just
made sense to write on my enrollment
form Bachelor of education secondary
majoring in English and history what I
didn't count on was one of the Faculty
of Education professors at the time who
was walking up and down the queue of new
students he came to me and without so
much as saying hello plucked the
academic transcript out of my hand he
looked it up and down and seeing that
I've done a reasonable amount of
mathematics at school told me on the
spot that I should consider becoming a
mathematics teacher and then you spent
the next 20 minutes convincing me about
Australia's critical shortage of skilled
passionate mathematics teachers and how
desperately we needed people to take up
their mantle there's an old joke that
primary teachers go into teaching
because they love kids secondary
teachers go into it because they love
their subject and tertiary teachers go
into it because they love themselves
maybe that means that deep down I'm a
primary school teacher because the thing
that drew me to education in the
beginning was my desire to work with
children and to help them flourish it
didn't matter to me so much what subject
I would teach I just wanted to be useful
and that's how I found myself preparing
to teach mathematics but while I was at
university studying my mathematics
degree a funny thing happened I
discovered what mathematics actually was
you see I'd always struggled with
mathematics in high school it never came
easily to me and I see now that was
because I fundamentally misunderstood
the subject to teenage me mathematics
was about memorizing arcane rules
I didn't comprehend to solve contrived
problems that I didn't care about it was
about gaining answers and getting them
fast but a university I started to learn
it mathematics is less about finding
answers fast and more about slowing down
to ask the right questions
I learned that mathematics is not about
mindlessly stepping through algorithms
but rather about imagining new ways to
see problems so they can be solved with
creative and unexpected techniques and I
began to understand that far from being
an abstract pursuit reserved for those
in ivory towers mathematics is woven
into absolutely every aspect of our
lives from the patterns of nature all
around us so the foundations on which
all of human society has been built the
beautiful spiral of seeds on a sunflower
the pristine crystalline symmetry of a
snowflake the millions of perfectly
hexagonal cells crafted by the world's
greatest civil engineers in beehives
around
planet the enormous prime numbers that
keep your credit cards safe online the
reason why when you bike away of your
lunch half of it burns your mouth while
the other half is still icy cold all of
it is mathematics so I started to
appreciate why mathematics finds its way
into everything you say mathematics did
are far more than just numbers it's
about patterns and relationships it's
about the logic that animates the
universe and the connections between
everything around us and because
mathematicians speak in patterns we're
uniquely positioned to recognize the
common realities hiding underneath
things that seem completely different on
the outside have you ever noticed that
lightning bolts river deltas sprawling
gum trees and the network of blood
vessels running through your body all
have the same characteristic shape it
starts from a central line and then
splits off into ever smaller branches
every single one of them belongs to the
same mathematical family we
mathematicians call them fractals you
see poetry is the art of calling the
same thing by different names but
mathematics is the art of calling
different things by the same name it
takes a mathematician to see such
different objects rivers trees arteries
and recognize that they're all related
that they all share the same DNA this
power of mathematics has unlocked the
mysteries of the cosmos as Galileo said
mathematics is the language with which
God has written the universe it's
enabled us to perceive the curvature of
space-time and the microscopic
structures of the quantum realm but the
thing I want to highlight for you is the
way that just as math
it's scientific power mathematics has
social power one of my favorite things
I've done as a high school teacher is be
a touch football coach you could
probably tell I've never been an
especially athletic person so I relished
the opportunity to vicariously live out
my sporting dreams through the teams
that I used to coach but the reason I
loved coaching touch football so much
was not the sport itself there's nothing
to do with the tries or the passes or
the clever strategies it was all about
the kinds of people my students became
when they played they became disciplined
they learned to rely on each other they
came to appreciate the diverse strengths
of their teammates by playing this sport
each player became a different person
and the character would grow this is the
same reason why I'm a mathematics
teacher the main thing I love about
teaching mathematics is not the subject
itself though there is plenty to love
about it the main thing I love is that
through learning mathematics each
student becomes a different person and
their character grows they learn to
persevere through difficulty when an
answer isn't obvious they develop
clarity of thought and the ability to
argue logically and most importantly
than to see things from different
perspectives
you see mathematicians are like jewelers
we treat every object like a diamond
because we know that looking at it from
just a slightly different angle will
reveal a whole new kaleidoscope of
colors and faces this is what I do in my
classroom every day we take a single
object and we examine it algebraically
then we graph it and we consider it
visually then we deconstruct it into its
chigan or metric components then we
express it as a polynomial and we work
on it with
calculus every time we take a new
perspective we learn something new this
is how mathematical knowledge advances
and I like in any other field of
knowledge when we prove something is
true mathematically it's true forever
mathematics is never revised or refined
in terms of new evidence it never needs
to be because mathematics is timeless in
its truth and beauty that's why the
oldest names we study in school
Pythagoras and Euclid are mathematicians
because the theorems they articulated as
true now as the day they were first
discovered in an age where postmodern
relativism has gone mad with fake news
and alternative facts spread far and
wide I think we could all do with a good
dose of rock-solid provable truth to
conclude there are three messages that
I'd like you to take away with you and
contemplate as we celebrate our nation
of this Friday firstly this Australia
Day I invite you to be a mathematician
no way hold on don't run for the hills
just yet let me explain mathematics has
enabled us to design machines and
subatomic scales it's the backbone of
artificial intelligence that can play
chess drive cars and identify cancers
far better than humans ever could but
the thing I feel most strongly about and
it's tall the futuristic technology is
how mathematics can make us more human
you can be a mathematician by learning
to see things from a different
perspective when you do that with a
fellow human being we call that empathy
you can be a mathematician by being
curious about patterns think about your
local community and ask the tough
questions about why the social patterns
around us exist and how we can change
them for the better
when you look at people who seem so
different throughout our country who
look different and sound different and
believe different things you can be a
mathematician by looking at different
people and yet calling them all by the
same name
Australians secondly there's something I
want to emphasize to the current
generation of young people so many of
the stories you hear and the films you
watch tell you that if you want to find
fulfilment then you need to listen to
your heart and follow your passion but I
don't buy that I didn't come out of high
school passionate about mathematics
quite the opposite if you're a young
person trying to find your way in the
world I don't think you need to follow
your passion I think you have to become
passionate about following need seeing a
need is what set me on the path to
becoming a mathematics teacher Sienese
what led me to start filming my lessons
five years ago and putting them on the
internet fulfilment isn't found in
looking into yourself it's found in
looking to others and having a heart to
serve them with the gifts that you have
this is one of the things I love best
about teaching every child is gifted I
get the joy of discovering how they're
gifted and helping them learn to use
their gifts that's why I'm passionate
about what I do
passionate passion isn't something we
follow passion is something we form over
time as we discover what matters in the
world and how we can make an impact on
it further lastly let's learn to truly
value our schools and our teachers
education is being one of Australia's
greatest assets but things won't stay
that way unless we give educators the
cultural and capital support they need
to do their jobs for instance that
shortage of mathematics teachers that I
was talking to you about has only become
more severe
since my university days as a field
education struggles to attract the
students with a lifelong passion for
changing the world for good and it's
even more of a challenge to keep them
there with all this half of our early
career teachers leaving the profession
in their first five years they want to
job with better work/life balance and
more respect from society and who can
blame them Australian teachers are often
undervalued and overworked certainly
those who are willing to make the
sacrifices stay that needs to change
Valene education isn't about awards and
accolades it's much more about trust and
respect parents politicians managers in
the media we all must do our part in
honoring our schools and the people who
work in them our children are depending
on it how do we do this we just need to
open our eyes to the everyday heroism
happening all around our great country
Australia Day is a time to sit up and
marvel at all the wonderful act of
selflessness and sacrifice that go
unnoticed around us every day as I
mentioned before working in a school
gives me a vantage point to so much of
this care and dedication I know teachers
who run early morning breakfast clubs
because they know that's the only way
that some of their students can start
the day with a square meal I know a man
who moved more than 500 kilometers east
of Kalgoorlie because he knows that the
tiny indigenous community where he's a
principal is capable of achieving
learning outcomes
hires anyone in the country I know two
of my own colleagues at Cherry Brook who
spent a whole year training with a group
of at-risk teenage boys to do a 24 hour
50 kilometer endurance hike they did it
to raise the funds for the children of
fallen Australian soldiers to give them
a sense of camaraderie to show them
they're more than just troublemakers in
school to help them understand what can
be achieved when we work together for
the sake of others these are the stories
unfolding in schools around Australia
that show what we are made of as a
people and these stories are everywhere
they're over your back fence and beside
you on the train everyone has one and
everyone's story is worth learning from
my story being a teacher is how I
learned that regardless of who they are
or where they live all children can
flourish in this ever-changing world if
they receive a great education in my
story being a lover of English and
history is how I learned that
mathematics can help us appreciate and
understand the world in a richer and
deeper way than any of us ever imagined
in my story being a Christian is how I
learned that serving others through
self-sacrifice is always always worth
the cost
in my story being an Asian and the son
of migrants is how I learned that hard
work and perseverance are far more
important than talent and in my story
being an Australian is how I learned
that all of those qualities are worth
valuing and paying forward to the
community that I am so proud to be a
part of these are lessons from my story
yours will be different that's why we
need to hear each other's so this
Australia Day as you celebrate commit
yourself to discovering someone's story
and appreciating their unique
contribution
to our beautiful country happy Australia
Day thank you
[Applause]